here's Jane Fonda talking about killing
people we have experienced many decades
now of having agency over our body of
being able to determine when and how
many children to have we know what that
feels like we know what that's done for
our lives we're not going back I don't
care what the laws are we're not going
back
because the women will rise up that's
the activist that's James speaking and
then and she probably will get a Nobel
Prize
it is the truth I'm not going to do it
and protesting what else do you suggest
[Laughter]
well let me talk to you about it
foreign
let's move on and talk about Jane's
activism which is look I don't want to
make a big stink of whether she was
joking or not like she was joking to
some degree and then they try to get her
out of it and then she slyly with the
real eye roll does this thing like oh
I'm not joking does she really want to
kill people who don't want abortion
actually I think it's possible I really
do like if your whole rationale is I
want to kill babies then maybe you would
kill some people maybe but the point is
if this was flipped in Reverse if the
view ever had a pro-life activist on and
they were like well what would you like
to do with people who provide abortion
abortions and they were like kill them
murder that would be good that person
would never be on television again
they're all of their gigs would be
canceled they would be banned gone
canceled adios amigos
[Music]
thank you